erica would you mind reading a page or
two from your book
i just so happened to have it on my lap
right okay
i would be happy to like i'm like a
teacher
this is chapter 16.
it's called own your power okay
your dream comes from the most powerful
place
you it's born from divine inspiration
one of the most powerful forces in the
universe
this calling becomes a burning desire
one that gives you ambition perseverance
drive
and even compassion in a way you've
never felt before
it helps form the most powerful version
of you there ever was
and yet the moment it becomes an
impossible feat you have to achieve
the power is immediately stripped away
it's your superpower and kryptonite all
in one
but the stripping of your power is
really an illusion
it's a choice to give it away and a
choice you don't
have to make instead of feeling at the
mercy of others to make your dream come
true
you can take your power back by
realizing as abraham hicks says
they are all just pawns in the law of
attraction game
you get to control so much more than you
think
you get to control your energy your
vibration your beliefs your strategy
your actions your risks and asks
and the most important of them all you
get to create
your reality all of those things
combined with the belief in abundance
and limitless opportunities leads to a
world where
it doesn't matter if someone says yes or
no to you
the dream is happening no matter what
i think one of my superpowers is
reminding people how
powerful they really are that shift in
energy can be
all it takes to manifest exciting new
opportunities
because how you show up to the world is
how the world will show up for you
whatever you believe will be reflected
back to you
if you feel powerless in your dream
pursuit
you will have experiences that confirm
those feelings
and vice versa ps
owning your power is so much more fun so
let's choose that shall we let me help
you by busting the power myths that your
subconscious is fighting for
here is one of the power myths
gatekeepers
gatekeepers are like the bouncers of the
club deciding who gets
in it feels like they have all the power
and
artists are at the mercy of their
decision
actors are at the mercy of casting
directors
authors are at the mercy of publishers
startups are at the mercy of
investors it feels like these
gatekeepers are in charge of our fate
and we have no control over what they
say
access to our dreams is in their hands
so
how are we supposed to feel powerful in
those moments
we hold none of the power in those
decisions
clap that's me waking you up from the
hypnotic spell you're under
time for the powerful truth powerful
truth
these gatekeepers do not determine your
fate
only you can do that pillar number seven
says that your success is inevitable
which means your fate has
already been decided any single
gatekeeper
or any single opportunity will not break
your chances of succeeding
it's already been decided
your success is a done deal
who cares what the gatekeeper says your
person is coming
your opportunity is coming because
it's inevitable and if that's the case
what if these gatekeepers were in fact
allies
what if they were friends what if
they were your support system your cheer
squad
what if the universe always place people
on your path to help you
and what if that help didn't always come
in the pretty package you want a no
could be just as much a gift as a yes
when jack canfield's book was turned
down 144 times by publishers
what if that was all a gift because the
publisher he was meant to work with
happened to be the 145th
what if it's all working out perfectly
we tend to put gatekeepers on pedestals
because
we think they hold the power but
you hold the power take them down
from that pedestal they are just people
they are pawns in your game
and this game is in the highest good of
everyone
you know the value you bring you
know you were meant to do this so it
can't not work
out if this gatekeeper doesn't let you
in
it says nothing about your potential
it says nothing about your future or
your ability to succeed
it just wasn't a match but i promise you
your people are out there keep
going because they're looking for you
too
excellent that's just two pages
why did you choose that passage
well one because i think that it's
something a lot of people struggle with
i think that so many filmmakers feel
powerless in this industry and they are
constantly searching for ways to feel
powerful that's why a lot of people do
their own work
you know film their own projects because
they want to feel in control
and they feel like everything's out of
control so i wanted to read that
to address that you know exact thing i
think that there's so many ways that we
can feel
you know be in our own power without it
even having to be something as
literal as filming your own content um
and also because so many people have
read the beginning of the book the first
chapter and i think a lot of what we
talked about today was
stories from the first couple chapters
and so i wanted to share something from
the back of the book
the third section um
that to me feels like this is how a high
achiever thinks
you know a high achiever doesn't feel at
the mercy of gatekeepers they feel
that they have the power to create
whatever they want
and if something doesn't work out or
doesn't happen the way they wanted it to
that's okay it doesn't mean that it it's
not still gonna happen
and how did you feel writing that
chapter did it did
were you sort of empowered i mean as
you're writing it
were you almost transformed into another
world yeah i mean
everything i wrote i need to hear over
and over again you know i read my own
book a lot
and i'm not trying to say that in like a
super arrogant way but in a way of like
i needed to hear this again today
you know um yeah i really feel like i
i mean so much of the book came from
working with my clients and the work
that we've done
over several years now um but
i do feel like i sort of i don't want to
say channeled you know but
i just feel like it it came from a place
like i i felt like this was
this idea to write this book was
divinely sent to me like i just
i just got the idea it wasn't something
i strategic i didn't strategize and say
oh i should write a book
i was like i just felt this feeling of
like you ha
like you have to get this message out to
help people
you know and then when covent hit not to
be super morbid i was like
i have to get this message out before i
die what if i get coveted and die
like i was really feeling like i need to
finish this book i told my mom where
like my book files were on my computer
i was just a little fearful during you
know do it like during this pandemic
um but yeah i just i don't know i just
i really want more people to
to hear this message and hopefully it
will help transform you know their
careers
when you tell your clients this message
are they resistant
at first oh yeah i mean
yes and no and and myself as well you
know
i share this story with my clients a lot
when i was
first starting out you know really
embracing some of this for myself
i was working with a life coach and we
were talking about money abundance
in terms of money and
i was really struggling financially that
month and i said i'm so broke
i'm so broke i really need a haircut i
can't afford a haircut i can't afford
anything
she said erica you are an abundant
person you are so abundant you have
access to money
all around you and i said do you want to
look at my bank account
i have hardly any money in it
and i went back and forth with her
arguing
about how broke i was no you don't
understand
you need to hear me i am broke i am
struggling
i need to be heard and
my poor coach she was so patient and
kind with me
you know because i had so much
resistance and now of course looking
back i share that story because
when i look back now i can see like i
was really fighting
for my limitations i was fighting to
stay where i was i i wasn't
listening to her when she was you know
like it's like if i listened to her
like i i could have been open to
solutions like with the fedex logo right
there could have been solutions in front
of me that i didn't see because
i didn't want to see them i wanted to
instead prove
how broke i was so i myself have been
resistant
and um i've definitely had clients be
especially in terms of not not really
necessarily
the belief but the action that it should
then lead to
so for example like one time i worked
with a client who i was like you need to
change your day job
because her day job had her traveling a
lot and she
would travel for like at least one week
every month
so she was out of town a lot and i was
like you want to
audition and this is pretty pandemic you
know nothing with self tape
you want to audition and and you know
get representation and audition and
books work you're not even here to do it
this day job i understand that it's
supporting you but
you need a different day job that's
going to support
what you're actually trying to do
because right now it's blocking you
and it took her
i think like six weeks i mean it took
her weeks you know because
that's a scary thing you know that's
definitely a risk but
you know working through the mindset of
it of like believing that your success
is inevitable if you take this risk
a you you start to believe of course
there's another day job out there for me
of course i can believe that that's
possible that i can be financially
supported
in a day job that also gives me time to
audition you know
and stay in la at least and not be
traveling right it's like you have to
start to believe that things can work
out for you
even with these little things of i have
to believe not only that my success is
inevitable but that i can find a
different day job
i have to believe that i can be
financially supported you know yeah so
we worked through
you know shifting her beliefs and
eventually she came around
changed her day job got an agent right
away
booked her first co-star booked a lead
in a tv movie
you know so so things really shifted for
her but you know it's okay to have
resist
it's okay that it takes time i think as
long as you're open
to doing the work it doesn't have to
happen overnight
but if you're if you're open to doing
that work i think
then that's that's where the benefit
will be
when you had the the down period after
you had
moved out here got this great job and
then
the recession hit or was already in
motion
and i believe then the show was
cancelled
were you fighting for your limitations
oh yeah
oh yes um yes i really was and again it
goes back to you know i had those like
blinders on
of only seeing the problem and not
allowing myself to open
up to solutions i didn't
do nothing like i you know i'm an
ambitious person and i
i tried you know i put myself out there
i think i cold emailed a bunch of you i
i try to get another job
so it's not like i didn't do anything
but
i had those blinders on and i was
definitely
like you know it's like if my mom
suggested like oh you should you could
go for a drive or go down to the ocean
no mom i can't do that that means i have
to put gas in the car and i can't afford
gas
you know so it was like i was constantly
focused on the problem
um and fighting to stay there
essentially you know my mom was like
trying to tell me all these things that
could potentially help me
and it took me a long time to get to a
place where i stopped fighting for my
limitations and i finally
opened myself up to help
you